in 1944 just before the d-day invasion
general patton addressed his troops i'm
going to clean this up a little bit
because this is a family show general
patton said quote
we're not going to just shoot the sons
of lady dogs we're going to rip out
their living gd guts and use them to
grease the treads of our tanks we're
going to murder those lousy hun blank
suckers by the bushel effing basket war
is a bloody killing business you've got
to spill their blood or they will spill
yours rip them up the belly shoot them
in the guts when shells are hitting all
around you and you wipe the dirt off
your face and realize that instead of
dirt it's the blood and guts of what was
once your best friend beside you you'll
know what to do
that's how the military used to talk
yesterday the marine corps and the air
force tweeted out pictures of rainbows
and wished everyone a happy pride month
the marines declared their commitment to
quote fostering an environment free from
discrimination and treating quote all
equally with dignity and respect
now nice as all that sounds
that is not the job of the u.s military
the us military is not an hr department
at some millennial tech startup the job
of the military is to kill our enemies
at least it was
for years the military held out as one
of the last institutions to resist
leftist takeover
those days appear to be finished
today the radical leftists who run our
armed forces whine about white rage
they give patriotic servicemen the boot
for not taking the fouchy auchi they
cram the rhetoric of diversity equity
and inclusion down the throats of the
brave men and women who volunteer to
serve and kill the bad guys
the radicals who have taken control of
our military don't really care so much
about winning wars abroad they're much
more interested in winning the
ideological war at home and in that war
as far as the radicals are concerned the
enemy
is us
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from jj who says
can you imagine being the father of a
son who is a complete stud at women's
swimming how proud he must be when all
his friends are bragging about their
kids it's probably a little bit awkward
at the meet you're talking to the other
parents you say yeah my
daughter totally
she showed all your daughters didn't she
she she totally did a great job right uh
probably probably not when you want to
reach people with whatever sort of
message you've got you've got to check
out constant contact right now go to
constantcontact.com i love constant
contact i've used these guys since i was
about
20 no not even i'm sorry 19 i think was
the first time i used constant contact
on a campaign it's such a great tool for
communication for digital marketing for
small businesses for campaigns for
non-profits i've used them for years
they've got email marketing contact
management industry leading list growth
tools social media ads and more constant
contact helps small businesses connect
with customers find new ones and sell
online all from one easy to use platform
they've been trusted by millions of
businesses to help improve their
marketing they've got a 97
deliverability rate you can rest assured
that your customers and potential
customers are getting the right message
at the right time
they've got a simple interface they've
got easy to use platform that makes
contact management easier than ever list
growth tools generation landing pages
text to join these guys are just so
great to start your free digital
marketing trial today head on over to
constantcontact.com
the left has become
militant
this is true
in the us military where the woke
leadership of the pentagon is pushing
this stuff this is true throughout
corporate america this is true
throughout the government this is true
on our own website
last night we premiered matt walsh's
documentary what is a woman taking on
the transgender agenda
and this was
this was a direct shot at the cultural
left on the first day of pride month and
we knew it was going to be the biggest
subscription event of the year this was
the biggest
most ambitious expensive movie we've put
out there
matt flew to freaking africa to find the
answer to this question what is a woman
and some people who signed up to watch
it may have found that they had some
trouble at least for 15 minutes 20
minutes
we took a look at what was going on why
is the site down why isn't this working
we've now confirmed the daily wire came
under a sustained and significant ddos
attack
so
there was
some group
some individual or some group or some
group of groups
targeted the daily wire website
uh with a very sophisticated attack
because they didn't want you to see the
premiere of what is a woman because
they're so afraid of this one question
that deflates the entire transgender
ideology people don't want you to see
this movie okay they want to silence us
they want to shut us down and it's too
bad for them because this was the
largest premier event we've ever had in
the history of the daily wire we've got
lots and lots of new members more new
members than on any single day ever in
the history of this company and if you
want to watch if you want to become one
of those members
go to what is a woman dot com we really
need you to support this
you can you can see it now when we talk
about the military
the corporations especially finance
the daily wire is a pretty big company
started out in jeremy's pool house now
we've got lots and lots of employees and
a lot of money coming in and lots of
projects being pushed out
we have not taken money
from
private equity from
any of the ways that you can raise money
we have not taken money yet because very
often
when you raise money in that way
it comes with a lot of strings you've
got to kowtow to certain woke rules to
the esg rules environmental social and
governance policies you lose your soul
as a company when you take that kind of
money so we have always relied on our
listeners and
you guys have been so great and
subscribed and supported it and so
that's how we can produce this content
we need more of you to do that if you
want us to keep producing this kind of
content that gets the libs so upset that
they target us with ddos attacks if you
want to keep
keep this kind of content coming at the
moment that it matters right at the
start of pride month when we're going to
be living in just one giant rainbow for
the next 29 days
you've got to subscribe so you go to
whatisawoman.com
right now
you will get 25 off a new membership
thank you for doing that for the next
28 29 days things are going to get
super
duper
gay
really really gay okay and you saw it in
the military that was bad enough kind of
ironic too that the military is
promoting diversity that great speech i
read from george patton up there at the
top he has a whole section of that
speech where he says i don't want any of
this individualism crap okay you're in
the military you just you do what
everyone else is doing and you shoot and
you kill the enemy and you follow orders
diversity has no place in the military
when when servicemen
suit up and they're getting ready for
battle do they put on
diverses do they do they button up all
of their diverses and then go out there
to fight no they put on their uniforms
because diversity is not what you want
in the military you want absolute
uniformity
i'm not saying uniformity of race or
uniform but you want
uniformity
at a deep level you want everyone to be
doing
the same
thing and you don't want people
expressing their weird sexual desires or
appetites that has no place in the
military
if you have something eccentric or
unusual or distracting from the mission
repress it keep it to yourself it's not
about you it's about the country and
protecting the country and killing the
enemies that's what the military used to
be about but not even the military is
immune these days from all this wokeness
certainly corporate america is not
immune
we saw this yesterday with starbucks
starbucks announced
when we are recognized and accepted for
who we are our communities are stronger
for it during pride month we join our
lgbtqia
two
plus partners there's a two what does
the two stand for i don't know
partners employees in supporting trans
equality
who advocate for the acceptance and
understanding of transgender people so
starbuck's coming out as extremely gay
we knew starbucks was very very gay ever
since they premiered these sous-vide egg
bites that i think was the the proof
positive and they're very delicious egg
bites so there you have it as starbucks
and every other corporation in america
just about is going to be embracing the
rainbow you're seeing this at the level
of the government joe biden yesterday
tweeted out quote
during pride month we honor the
resilience of
lgbtqi plus people so no a no two very
discriminatory from biden
these people who are fighting to live
authentically and freely
we reaffirm that lgbtqi
plus rights are human rights
and we recommit to delivering
protections safe safety and equality
so everyone can realize the full promise
of america
it's an important point here because
you're going to hear this phrase a lot
lgbtq
writes
there is no such thing as lgbtq rights
it's a phrase that people will use
just like they invent all sorts of
rights these days but there is no right
to that
i'm not saying that people who have some
sexual confusion or an unusual sexual
identity don't have any rights they have
certain rights but there is no such
thing as lgbtqi
rights just because you say something is
a right doesn't mean that it is
rights are actually grounded in reality
if rights are to have any meaning at all
let's just take the t because it's the
clearest example
a man does not have a right to pretend
that he's a woman
that's actually wrong of him to do he
he if
if the source of our rights is just our
making a claim for them then there's no
end to that but of course there are no
such rights the
biden administration the left is trying
to invent civil rights to that but it
doesn't exist it's not it's not right at
all and this is not just about inclusion
and being very nice and being very
accepting this is very very aggressive
we we just saw yesterday
and this wouldn't be the first time
we've seen this the united states
government flying a pride flag
at the vatican
at the holy see
it says quote
today is the start of pride month the
united states respects and promotes the
equality and human dignity of all people
including the
lgbtqia plus community
hashtag pridemonth hashtag all inclusive
hashtag pride2022.
the libs are going to play this off and
say look this is just a positive
affirmation of our view of sexuality and
pride but it's not positive because they
don't do this in muslim countries they
don't do this in saudi arabia they don't
do this in places where they
where they think it's going to result in
a a bombing or a suicide attack
this is not about affirming lgbt this is
about attacking christianity this is
about attacking the traditions in the
west if it weren't they'd be flying
these flags in saudi arabia and
throughout the muslim world but they're
not because it's not it's not about the
rainbow it's not about lgbt it's about
saying
fu
to
tradition to our traditional
understanding of how to behave
in this country
in the month of june
we have three months we have pride month
that's the most prominent one
we have the month of the sacred heart of
jesus that's the traditional
catholic understanding of june and we
have national dairy month
since 1937 june has been national dairy
month okay
23 of america is catholic
at least if you if you
look at just identification with a
catholic family it's actually much
higher than that closer to about 50 but
people who say i am catholic 23
and yet the corporations
do not
promote the month of the sacred heart of
jesus
pretty much every american eats dairy
very few americans are lactose
intolerant so
lots of americans eat cheese drink milk
eat yogurt
the corporations do not pander to
national dairy month
at the highest possible percentage
according to gallup last year 7.1
percent of americans identify as lgbt so
why
all the rainbows
this is no slight on people who
have unusual sexual identities but why
we're talking about
a very distinct minority here why does
the rainbow have to cover everything
why because
lgbt
is effectively the established church of
our national government
it is lgbt
is a
moral system
it's a system that makes moral claims
about human identity about sexuality
about how we should behave about what
the family is about our relationship to
one another and it's disproportionately
supported by our elites it's not nearly
as supported by ordinary american people
this is why things like the redefinition
of marriage when they were put up to
votes would fail it would fail even in
california but then the elites who are
running our government from washington
dc in a more oligarchic fashion they
were always pushing this stuff
so that's why it's effectively an
established church and you don't have
the right to oppose it and you can see
that it's an established church because
now they're posing it in direct contrast
to christianity they're flying it over
the vatican what are you going to do
about it vatican we know you oppose this
we would never do this to another
religion in another sort of country
but to christianity we do because
because of the aggressiveness of this
political movement furthermore i'm not
the first person to come up with this
idea but but a number of people have
said it in recent years the rainbow flag
in some ways doesn't have very much to
do with sex it does in that sex is very
important to human nature
but it represents much more than sex now
it represents the flag of the american
empire
it represents the flag of the universal
values of liberation and individuality
that america is spreading throughout the
world
whereas the red white and blue the stars
and stripes represents the flag of the
american nation
the rainbow flag represents the flag of
the american empire if you took a poll
right now of conservatives and libs and
you said which flag do you identify more
with the stars and stripes or the
rainbow flag
obviously the conservatives would say
the stars and stripes what do you think
that libs would say
i bet you a huge proportion of the libs
maybe the majority of libs would say oh
i identify much more with the rainbow
flag the stars and stripes that's awful
that stands for oppression that stands
for slavery that stands for jim crow
but the rainbow flag that stands for
freedom inequality and liberation
liberation from all the bonds not just
the bonds of history not just the bonds
of tradition not just the bonds of
family but the bonds of human nature
itself
that's what they're doing so they're
going to celebrate this all month this
represents the the libs
the the logical or illogical conclusion
of the libs campaign for total
liberation
now after this once they liberate us
from biological sex then they're just
gonna have to liberate us from the
physical world entirely plug our brain
stems into the computer and then we'll
all be living in the matrix they're
already trying to do that but but we're
still probably a few years off so we we
should count our blessings for right now
speaking of celebrations speaking of
counting ones blessings
really great news for johnny depp the
trial
that has dominated america for the past
few weeks the defamation case from
johnny depp against his ex-wife amber
heard who accused johnny of beating her
the verdict finally came out yesterday
as to the statement appearing in the
online op-ed entitled amber heard i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
in the washington post online edition
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr deb proven by a greater weight of
the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard answer yes
the state question the statement was
about mr depp answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr depp
answer yes
question the
defamatory implication was designed and
intended by ms heard
answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication
to someone who saw it other than mr depp
answer yes
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice
answer yes
boom total victory judgment for johnny
depp for 15 million dollars
he
lost on one much lesser charge in the
countersuit from amber heard so i think
he lost on a 2 million dollar judgment
there but he won on the 15 million
judgment so this is just total
vindication for johnny depp why do i
care i don't particularly care about
johnny depp i don't i certainly don't
care about amber heard
it is important though
one i care because our daily wire makeup
artist has been absolutely obsessed with
this case and so i feel like i'm just
very invested in it
through osmosis because in the makeup
room i've heard a lot of this case but
two
because
this represents the death of the metoo
movement this represents the death of
time's up and believe all women no you
shouldn't believe all women because some
women are liars women just like men can
lie they can say things that aren't true
and in some cases women are stone-cold
sociopaths as it would appear this lady
is here just got caught in egregious
lies caught on tape admitting to lies
and threatening to destroy this guy's
career
so a total vindication for johnny depp
and an end of the me2 movement this all
stemmed from a 2018 op-ed that the
sloppy editors at the washington post
allowed amber heard to run so because of
the extremely low journalistic standards
at the washington post amber heard is
now bankrupt this is the most expensive
op-ed in the history of
journalism and that op-ed was a big part
of the me too movement as it was on the
rise
now that's all over amber heard issued a
statement
she said the disappointment i feel today
is beyond words i'm heartbroken that the
mountain of evidence still was not
enough to stand up to the disportionate
power influence and sway of my
ex-husband what are you talking about
lady
all of the influence all of the
political power was on your side we've
just come out of a movement where the
ubiquitous call around the country was
believe all women no matter how flimsy
their claims no matter how little
evidence they had all of the evidence in
this case was on the side of johnny depp
including you in your own words
admitting certain things
your closest confidants contradicting
what you were saying video evidence
contradicting the claims that you were
making
and even then the the only reason that
johnny depp won these cases is because
we had that video is because we had that
audio still there was so much power and
influence on your side
so she says this is a step back for
women this is so terrible and then she
says i believe johnny's attorneys
succeeded in getting the jury to
overlook the key issue of freedom of
speech
and ignore evidence that was so
conclusive that we won in the uk okay
this is great this is the key part here
she says i'm sadder still
than losing the case that i seem to have
lost a right i thought i had as an
american to speak freely and openly
she's saying that the fact that she's
not allowed to defame johnny depp
means that freedom of speech is dead in
america i'm so glad she brought this up
because maybe she thinks this sincerely
it seems like kind of a cynical take to
me but maybe she sincerely thinks that
and she should be corrected
there is no freedom of speech to
defamation
you don't freedom of speech doesn't mean
you can just say whatever you want i
wrote a book about this called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is coming out in paperback
this month
you know
tomorrow is the mailbag day it's my
favorite time of the week
you can submit not only your text
mailbag questions but your voice mailbag
questions and you can only do that if
you are a daily wire member
yet another reason to become a daily
wire member so
if you wouldn't mind please keep the
voicemail to under 60 seconds sometimes
people want to tell me their whole life
story we don't have time for that on the
show we got to get to a lot of questions
so head on over right now to
dailywire.com
knowles or use the promo code knowles
for 10 off and become a member and send
those voice mail bags in we'll be right
back with a lot more
amber heard claiming that her loss in a
defamation case is the death knell for
free speech is really rich first of all
because the libs in this country have
been attacking the legitimate tradition
of free speech in america for years now
but also there's never been a right to
defamation
she reminds me of of the dad on south
park of randy on south park where he's
acting drunken and belligerent he's
finally arrested he says i thought this
was america what i thought what happened
to freedom i thought this was america
here what you mean i can't no you can't
act belligerently and and out of order
there are limits to what you can say and
do there's no free speech protection to
fraud there's no free speech protection
to fighting words there's no free speech
protection to obscenity for that matter
it ties right in with the whole
theme of pride month which is we have
the freedom to do whatever we want
that's not freedom
we have the right to do whatever we want
you it's not what a right is
in the words of edmund burke people do
not have the right to do things that are
not reasonable and not to their benefit
you do not have the right to cut off a
healthy arm just because you have some
fantasy about wanting to be crippled you
do not have the right as far as i'm
concerned to cut off other healthy body
parts just because you have a sexual
problem or confusion and a sick cruel
society is encouraging that delusion in
you you don't have any right to that
that's actually very very wrong
rights are reasonable things
rights are in accord with reality and
logic and reason and what is beneficial
to you and what leads to human
flourishing
do you know how hard it is to win a
defamation case in america it's very
very hard
we have robust speech protections here
and still the evidence was so clear here
that heard was living in a fantasy world
well it's not just amber heard living in
that fantasy world defining her own
truth her own reality it's everybody in
this country these days
this goes back to planned parenthood v
casey to one of the worst supreme court
decisions in american history where the
romantic poet of the court anthony
kennedy said that people
at the heart of liberty lies the right
to define our own concept of existence
of the mystery of human life there is no
right to define your concept of
existence there is an obligation to live
in accord with reality that that's an
obligation
if we're all just defining our own
concept of existence society is going to
break down instantly
because we can't communicate with one
another because our misbegotten notions
of rights and entitlements are going to
come into conflict with one another the
legitimate right of a woman to use the
women's bathroom in peace
conflicts with the pretend right of a
sexually confused man to go into the
women's bathroom those both can't be
rights you'd both of those people don't
have the right to define their own
concept of existence actually neither of
them do they both have an obligation to
accept
reality
speaking of irresponsible speech from
amber heard there's really irresponsible
speech coming out from rand paul's
democrat opponent in the kentucky senate
race this guy he's a black guy and he
decided he was going to play the race
card as hard as he possibly could in
this ad and he decided that he was going
to insinuate that rand paul is a racist
it's the worst thing you can possibly be
called in america today and he was going
to do the ad with a noose around his
neck
the pain of our past
persists to this day that news hanging
in kentucky like many states throughout
the south lynching was a tool of terror
it was used to kill hopes for freedom
it was used to kill
my ancestors wow look he's got a new son
is that a historic victory for our
commonwealth who put that i have become
the first black people to receive the
democratic nomination for u.s senate
my opponent
the very person who compared expanded
health care to slavery
the person who said he would have
opposed paul rights act that guy is
basically in the kkk
can you believe rand paul put that noose
around that guy's neck
very news to him i don't think rand paul
knows he did that but that's what this
guy is insinuating together or do we let
politicians like rand paul forever hold
us back and drive us the news
in november
we will choose healing we will choose
healing in november we're going to
choose healing and i'm going to do that
by insinuating that my opponent is a
terrorist who hates all black people and
wants to kill us all
because we're because we we like healing
and inclusion and tolerance and
diversity
i love this ad this ad tells you
everything you need to know about race
relations in america today and about the
left's very cynical
campaign strategy
who put the noose on that guy's neck
was it the grand
wizard of the kkk no
does the kkk even exist i'm skeptical of
that was it rand paul no
that guy
that guy that senate candidate put the
noose around his own neck and he had to
do that because he knows that the the
easiest way for him to win the best shot
he's got at winning is to pretend to be
a victim but he's not a victim
the easiest shot he has at winning is to
pretend that america is hunting down
black people willy-nilly and but that's
not happening and so he's got to pretend
he's got to do it himself one time i was
at an event at loyola marymount i was
giving a speech with drew
and we were both on stage
talking about whatever i mean this was
not this was not the most controversial
speech we've ever given
and it was during blm
the early days of blm and in comes
a group of black students dressed all in
black
with tape on their mouths
black tape like they're censored like
they're being silenced they can't speak
so i i looked at this group of very odd
odd-looking people and i said hey guys i
don't know exactly what's going on here
but uh if you feel like you're being
silenced here's the microphone come
speak anyone who's got the tape on his
mouth come up here and you can say
whatever you want to say i don't think
you have very much to say not sure
there's a whole lot going on up there
between the ears but if you have some
pressing point that you feel is being
censored come on up and say it
none of them did it
because i didn't put the tape on their
mouths and drew didn't put the tape on
their mouths and you didn't put the tape
on and rand paul didn't put the tape on
their mounds
they put the tape on their own mounds
they had to do that
because
they feel that they can make their point
gain a social advantage by pretending to
be the victims of some awful oppression
and no one is there to oppress them
which is very inconvenient for them and
so they've got to oppress themselves
look at this noose around my neck you
put the noose on your neck same thing
with what's his face in chicago jesse
smilet
jesse smell it he was so eager he said
please let there be a ku klux klan
member here
in this downtown chicago you know mega
country downtown chicago why won't
anyone attack me all right i'll put the
noose on my own neck and i'll hold my
subway sandwich
there this is there is so much deep
meaning to this this kentucky senate ad
and it's the opposite of of what this
guy is suggesting also worth pointing
out by the way now that we're all
playing the victim
the italians were the victims of the
largest mass lynching in american
history okay where's my sympathy where
are my pity votes all right we don't
hear about it it was 1891 louisiana 11
southern italians were lynched
you don't hear about that you don't read
about that of course lynching hasn't
been a problem in america at all
so for what 70 years i think there was
one lynching in the 70s or 80s
that was it
i'm not saying that's good but crimes
happen folks i mean how many you know
just over memorial day weekend over 40
people were shot in chicago and 10 of
them were killed okay there were
violent crimes in america are you
telling me one lynching in the last
60 years
or thereabouts and then lynching was
only really a
major problem in america through what
the 40s i think
the about the 1880s to the 1940s but
we've got to pull that back we haven't
had enough problems in the last 60 years
we got to pull it back if i am to get
elected we need to contrive victimhood
this is what happened yesterday with
disney
i do not follow disney very closely i do
not follow star wars i liked the star
wars movies when i was a kid i liked
star wars one
the real one you know the first movie a
new hope
i liked number two i like number three
and i even frankly i even kind of like
jar jar binks and the prequels i did all
right i look i was a child what did i
know but i haven't really followed it
since then
they've added lots of new characters
apparently disney is going to add a new
character played by moses ingram
and moses ingram is a black woman and
she is upset because apparently when
they announced her character she got
some mean tweets so her colleague who
plays obi-wan kenobi ewan mcgregor just
came out and castigated the star wars
audience the fans the people who pay his
bills castigated the disney subscribers
as racists
this weekend star wars fans made obi-wan
kenobi
the most watched disney plus original
series premiere of all time and for that
i would say a big thank you
and it just goes to show what this
family can do when we all pull together
however
it seems that some of the fanbase from
this influential fan base
have decided to attack moses ingram
online and send her the most horrendous
racist dms
and i hired some of them this morning
and it just broke my heart
moses is a brilliant actor she's a
brilliant woman
and she's absolutely amazing in this
series she brings so much to the series
she brings so much to the franchise
and it just sickened me to my stomach to
hear
that this had been happening i just want
to say as the
leading actor in the series as the
executive producer in the series
that we stand with moses we love moses
and if you're sending her bullying
messages you're no star wars fan in my
mind there's no place for racism in this
world
and uh i totally stand with moses
this is the new current thing the new
current thing just dropped it's stand
with moses
i kind of like that idea you know if
we're talking about like the og moses i
like that idea stand with the bible that
would be that'd be quite a message for
pride month
stand with moses referring to this
actress is is the thing no longer are we
talking monkey pox that's gone that only
lasted a few days
uh the ukraine war that's totally out of
the news that current thing is now a
past thing
that's a covid that's over now stand
with moses change your profile pictures
folks get it up there on your twitter
banners we stand with moses for what
what happened
what exactly happened here this woman
got a very
high-paying prominent sought-after job
in hollywood in a beloved franchise but
she got
some mean tweets i guess
and so now we need to stand with moses
uh this is what this actress said about
it she said the thing that bothers me is
this feeling inside of myself that no
one has told me
but this feeling that i have to shut up
and take it that i have to grin and bear
it and i'm not built like that so i
wanted to come on and say thank you to
the people who show up for me in the
comments and the places that i'm not
going to put myself and to the rest of
y'all y'all weird
she says it's awful this idea this awful
idea that i have to shut up and take it
i have to grin and bear it
moses i don't know you
you have to grin and bear it you have to
if it not just if you're getting mean
tweets if you're getting mean tweet i
mean good i could tweet out good morning
and let me read to you the replies that
that let me read to you the dms that
comes from that from the left okay if
any person i'm not complaining about it
every person who is in any way in public
life and a lot of people who are in
private life on social media get
extremely mean
tweets and extremely mean comments you
have to toughen up if you want to be in
public life you don't need to be in
public life you can go just get married
and raise family and attend home you can
do that if you want i'm sure a guy would
be happy to do that with you you have
chosen to be in public life
being in public life entails criticism
being in public life entails mean unjust
vicious attacks that's just what
happens that you
ah it ties in even with this this point
about the military early on the military
used to be georgie patton there saying
listen here i've had enough of this
bilia's bs about doing your own thing
individuality we're going to go there
like s-h-i-t through a tin horn we're
going to rip our enemy up the belly and
wipe the blood and guts of our friends
off our face without shedding a tear
darn it you know that used to be the way
that we spoke and not just in the third
army
not just in the military threat all of
society used to be oh you
you got us you scraped your knee rub a
little dirt on it and move on
oh someone called you a mean name well
sticks and stones can break my bones but
words can never hurt me toughen up good
grief fortitude is a virtue
fortitude is a is a very important
virtue because if you don't have
fortitude you're not gonna be able to
defend any of the other virtues
your you are in this actress is in
one of the most privileged positions in
the entire world people would kill to
have this job that she does and she says
well
someone on twitter said something mean
to me by the way
they're making it about race because
racism is the worst thing racist is the
worst thing you can be called today
i
strongly suspect that people who are
who may or may not be attacking her for
her race
aren't even doing that because they
don't like black people i've made this
point before and drew cleveland has made
this point a lot too
when
when you attack somebody and you call
someone a racial slur or a sexual slur
or any other kind you or you attack
their family and you say your mom is so
fat or whatever
very often most most of the time i think
you are not doing so because you don't
like people of their race or you don't
like people of their sex or sexual
desire or you don't like their mother or
you think they want these fat you're
doing it
because you don't like the person that
you're insulting or you don't like the
thing that the person represents or what
the action that the person has
undertaken and so you're you're
attacking their characteristics just
because it's convenient just because
that's the thing you see
i made the point on the show the other
day if our giant polish ad the assistant
director on the show pavel
for whatever reason is is you know
really just gets my blood up one day
i i might say pavel you dirty rotten
filthy giant pollock am i would i be
well i wouldn't say that because i would
be ground to dust in a moment but if i
did that would it would i be saying that
because i don't like polish people no i
like polish people very much i would
just be saying it because i i would in
that case theoretically be angry at
povel and that's the first thing that
comes to mind but now now we all have to
claim victimhood because that carries a
currency and if you can accuse your
opponents of racism that's the greatest
win of all because that that will
basically anathematize your opponent
that will that will ostracize them and
and these days it could de-platform them
it could kick them out of the public
square it could remove them from the
political community
the future
not looking
not looking very bright
i i always have hope because hope is a
theological virtue but my priest friend
father george rutler made the point that
the difference between a scottish
optimist and a scottish pessimist is
that a scottish pessimist says things
can't get any worse and a scottish
optimist says oh yes they can and i'm
sort of in the latter category there so
i have hope but things are looking like
they're going to get a lot worse i saw
this from ikea of all places the cheap
swedish furniture company so when you go
and buy ikea furniture
one thing you can do is go to their
cafeteria which i always used to like to
do in college or if i was buying
furniture in new york as a bachelor i'd
go and you could get swedish meatballs
you could get all sorts of nice cheap
food for lunch so they've got a kitchen
where they're developing new food some
of the new food they're developing
ikea joining the rest of the
liberal institutions they're trying to
make us
eat bugs
it's served with hydroponically grown
leaves and salt and vinegar sprinkled
insects
each element is designed to be
sustainable but also tasty so what it
actually tastes like
so i think this is probably the most
sci-fi thing that i've ever eaten they
don't taste of that much themselves
they're kind of
slightly nutty
the salt and vinegar is really nice a
nice snack on the side nice little snack
on the side to just eat the little worms
that they're putting in my taco yeah
it's really nice i really like it and
you look at his face and he's obviously
disgusted by this
but for whatever reason he's going to
pretend oh no this is really good yeah
it's sort of like if you've ever gone to
a tasting menu i've had the misfortune
of going to tasting menus on occasion
they're these very fancy things that
millennials do in cities where you go
and it's not that the food is ever
particularly good it's just expensive
and weird and you sit down at a tasting
menu and they say all right for our
first dish well one time i was at a
tasting menu and they served essentially
tofu dippin dots
and one time they served me a big
heaping plate of raw veal raw veal in
mayonnaise
and then after that a little sliver of
extremely pungent smoked haddock and
you're
you're sitting there and i went to this
restaurant because my friend asked if i
would go and i said okay that's fine and
everyone around the table has to pretend
that it's good
you say oh yeah nothing nothing i like
after scobbling down a nice bowl of raw
veal nothing i like more than extremely
pungent smoked fish ooh but hold on save
room for the tofu dippin dots after no
it's just
but people all pretend because this is
very sophisticated and cool and
futuristic and
nowhere is this truer than on the
freaking bugs for whatever reason every
liberal institution wants us to eat bugs
the world economic forums always in the
future
in the future we're going to eat bugs oh
it's a great source of protein
okay if it's such a great source of
protein you eat it i'm gonna eat steak
and hamburgers and chicken and you can
eat bugs
no no you have to eat bugs because
you're the filthy dirty masses the poor
people you have you do that we're gonna
continue to eat our filet mignon
now this is futuristic that's probably
true it's so
extremely dystopian that we're all going
to be just locked in our rooms plugged
into the neural link or we apply with
our brain stems in the matrix just
eating bugs all the time that is so
extremely dystopian that it probably is
the future that probably will come true
when that guy in the video says this is
the most sci-fi thing i ever ate right
when you think of sci-fi movies the
really the really influential sci-fi
stories
books
they tend not to be utopian
they tend to be pretty dystopian
actually and so it is very sci-fi yes
gobbling up bug tacos is definitely very
dystopian speaking of our dystopian
future you know i hate to say i told you
so you know i hate to take that that
nostradamus hat and my crystal ball out
and predict the future because it's
distressing when i predict something
unpleasant in the future but i told you
months ago when the libs started to pull
their foot off the pedal on covid
i said don't believe it they're going to
bring kovid back they're going to bring
all the covid measures back they're not
actually getting rid of the power grab
that they took over the last two years
they're trying to keep the national
emergency authorization they're trying
to keep a lot of the public health
orders they're trying to keep a lot of
the vaccine mandates
well now joe biden is trying to bring
back that stupid mass mandate on the
airplanes
probably the least logical the least
reasonable of all the covid measures the
airplanes were never a major source of
coveted transmission if you put the mask
on and you're sitting arm to arm
shoulder to shoulder and then you pull
the mask down to eat and drink it's just
preposterous that that's going to stop
you from getting kovid
these flimsy little disgusting masks it
was always a joke he's trying to bring
it back
because the libs will need covet it was
hurting them in the polls so they backed
off covet a little bit they backed off
fouchy a little bit they put him in an
underground bunker but they're all
coming back okay
they're all coming back the moment that
it is politically convenient for
the libs
this is because biden has nothing to run
on right now
the washington post just reported this
joe biden is finally
at least privately admitting that
inflation is really bad it's really
hurting americans really hurting
democrats chances but he's not taking
any responsibility he's blaming his
aides and his assistants according to
the wapo biden has privately grumbled to
top white house officials over the
administration's handling of inflation
expressing frustration over the past
several months that aides were not doing
enough to confront the problem directly
people are knocking biden for not taking
responsibility here you know the buck
stops with my aid but i i think he's
actually got a fair point because joe
biden is obviously not running the
country joe biden is obviously not
particularly lucid a lot of the time
the aides are running the country
the personnel the assistance the
bureaucracy that's running the country
half the time joe biden doesn't know
what end is up and so you could blame
joe biden for being a feckless empty
suit figurehead
but he's not the one actively making
this call these calls i don't think
anyone believes that
it's the aids it's the geniuses it's the
phds it's all the fancy people from all
the elite institutions pushing really
really really radical ideas cramming
them down the throats of the rest of us
infecting every single institution in
this country up to and including the
leadership of the us military and
they're so convinced that their vision
of the future is wonderful and we
they've just got to get over the the
awful hump of the people pushing back on
them well every time they grab more
power every time they advance their
agenda a little a little further we end
up in in a country that is less
recognizable less good less pleasant
and frankly dystopian i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily
dailywire2022.
hey there this is john bickley dailywire
editor-in-chief and co-host of
morningwire on today's episode the jury
sides with johnny depp canada imposes
new gun bans and the supreme court
blocks a law against viewpoint
discrimination by platforms join us and
get the facts first on the news you need
to know with our show morning wire